[Music]
so now that I'm over 40 I I'm almost
respectable I learn a little thing tank
at the London School of Economics where
we research the new breeds of propaganda
campaigns and we think about what to do
with them well how to count them but
that's not not how I I started when I
left University just a few years ago I
did one of the most despicable lowest
dirtiest and least respectable things
imaginable I helped make reality shows
and to make it even more out there I
went to make up in Russia I was in film
school in Russia Rotter University
somewhere it's somewhere here and and
ended up working in the Russian
entertainment industry in the early
Putin years 2001 to 2010 and uh you know
I thought of film school I dreamt of
making these beautiful art movies and
long-form documentaries that's not what
the market wanted the market wanted the
Russian version of The Apprentice and so
the company that I work for that they
made stuff like the Russian version of
The Apprentice which is fascinating
because uh you know unlike in America
they had a real Russian businessman who
kind of was the Donald Trump figure from
corn island actual actual oligarch and
the show was beautifully made you know
Western consultants help story lines all
beautifully produced and it failed
miserably because the Russian audience
just wouldn't admit that that's how you
make your money by doing all these
little sort of you know business
challenges Russians know that rush you
make your money by you know embezzling
loads of money through a minister or
sending the map you're out to get
someone and if you do have a brilliant
business brain chances are you'll end up
in Siberia or in the gulag
other reality shows that incredibly well
in Russia survive oh you know we take a
bunch of people and you throw them onto
an island and they have to survive or
die
that is really one in Russia because you
know that relates the Russian cultural
experience
oh it's the Gulag we get this yes I
didn't amazingly well and they are still
going but the reason I'm some dudes will
detour through Russian reality shows is
but by working in the Russian
entertainment industry I'm actually
closed off sort of the emergence of what
seems to me a new type of propaganda
propaganda was always you know very very
important role in the Soviet Union
Lenin thought propaganda to create a new
society humanity mentality a new
communist utopia a new future so there
was nothing new about some Russian TV
man I just seen themselves as demigods
but my colleagues who worked who ran
Russian TV and works inside Russian TV
know they seems to be some discovering
new forms of rhetoric and new forms of
messaging that seem very different to me
they tried to sum them up in the book I
wrote about my time in Russia the book
was called nothing is true and
everything is possible which is an
attempt to kind of you know grab the
essence of this obvious new breed of
propaganda and there are a few kind of
main themes that I try to cut out of it
one that politicians no longer care if
they were caught lying if anything that
seems kind of rejoice in the fact they
didn't care about that
so like sort of story so your propaganda
with this fake because telling you you
know how they're achieving the socialist
utopia you have these politicians even
cameras see in the nineteen nineties
already relied and kind of love light
and with that you know something else Oh
disappeared from from the Russian
political discourse there's no idea of
the future anymore they're just these
misty nostalgia's about raising Russia
from its needs no clear ideology no left
or right just a you know a politics of
pure emotion and this weird sense that
language was losing meaning that
political categories communists liberal
Democrat no party through these names
didn't mean it anymore
the Communists were basically these I
know sort of capitalists with a bit of
Russian flops thrown in know some
Liberal Democrat Party thurr was neither
liberal nor Democrats
it was just like language of drifter
around these words drifting around
without any kind of story attached to
them so but the essence of me will
redefine this propaganda was that they
weren't trying to prove anything to you
there if I make you doubt everything
we're trying to give you the sense the
truth is unknowable which was weirdly
effective because if you live in a world
we can never prove anything with facts
don't really exist where everything is
just this endless sequence of
conspiracies they knew have no agency
you know you can't change anything as
well so it's a weirdly effective way of
getting people to kind of submit to
Putin
so around it was a slow move 2010 11 12
I kind of relocate back to London
because I'm like I can't live in a
reality as warped as the Russian one
anymore
I want to go back to the West for all it
sports you know politicians you know can
be held accountable by the truth and
they mean what they say and political
parties conservative labor they stand
for clear political ideas and lo and
behold 2016 rolls on and so many of the
pathologies that I'd see manifest
themselves in Russia suddenly burst out
here in the UK in America where I do a
lot of my watch and I think also in
Europe maybe not quite so strongly but
certainly emerging that and to the new
book I wrote handily title this is not
propaganda is an attempt to understand
this why did the future arrive first in
Russia well the future is present when
you come to Russia first is this an
accident or we seen something very
systemic happen across the world and if
it's something systemic what do we do
about it the new book is not a Russia
book it takes move around the world
because I wanted to see are these
phenomena everywhere so I go to South
Asia to the Middle East Latin America to
kind of strong resilient democracies
like Germany and and ones that are so
polarized they're on the edge of
collapse like Ukraine and the United
States of America and um basically what
I discover is a landscape where the
foundational principles axioms metaphors
that we had for a healthy democratic
deliberative the
Christie let's call it that no we're all
debate with each other and have a have a
common exchange of use and and reach
decisions they collapsed well there
aren't a huge stress so ideas like that
we live in a marketplace of ideas where
the more information you have the best
information will eventually win out in
some kind of theory of rational choice
or the pluralism you know will mean a
better and more productive debate or
there are freedom of expression is the
way to stand up to the powerful or
indeed the truth can hold the powerful
accountable now some of the reasons for
this I think are to do with technology I
spend quite a lot of time in the
Philippines during this book which is a
very interesting place because it has
one of the highest not the highest use
of social media per capita it's a place
where when you buy your mobile phone
it'll be hardwired to Facebook so
Facebook is your internet base it's a
true social media Society and there you
have a leader Rodrigo Duterte who a
little bit like the authoritarian
leaders of the 20th century who you
openly admires goes after critical
voices yeah he goes after opposition but
he doesn't do this in the way that
authoritarianism the twentieth century
did it he doesn't do it by constricting
the information space he doesn't do it
through censorship he doesn't even do it
through the secret police coming round
and knocking on your door instead he
does it through these kind of mass
coordinated campaigns of cyber malicious
online troll factories their attack and
undermine the reputation of independent
journalists and opposition's they seem
to be coming out of everywhere out of
Twitter and through your emails and out
of Facebook and when the journalist oh
hold on this is us under attack from the
regime the regime guys no these are just
concerned citizens showing their freedom
of expression you know they're not
saying they're not inciting to murder
you they're just saying we don't trust
you
we think you're fake news you know all
the banality that we hear from a Trump
you know you Democrats you always fought
for freedom of expression well here it
is and go and prove that we've
commissioned these people
might be real people you can't prove it
it's unlike you suspect that it's called
Nixon you might have a whistleblower or
two but that's not a lot prove to nail
our connection to this it's very funny
when the Russian troll factory who I'm
sure you've all heard of when they
started having their pages taken down by
Facebook they did this sort of like you
know they put out these statement saying
hold on what about our freedom of
expression you know this is off being of
expression to tell lies on the American
internet but they have a point that you
have a very good point if you go into
international humans from human rights
law article 19 of the egg-whites
declaration interest the one about
freedom of expression there's nothing in
there about this information this
information lying fake news that's not a
legal regulatory category yeah that's an
accepted part of a marketplace of ideas
and there's another way I think
technology has undermined some of the
virtues we associated with freedom of
expression so in the book I go back to
the Cold War a lot to the twentieth
century actually through a family memoir
but on there was always an association I
think the twentieth century between
self-expression and self-empowerment
self-expression and emancipation the
power will try to squeeze you while you
would you know shout your story and
yourself and you're right for the world
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas